try to start garbage right now everybody
I am dark Diva Barbie you're welcome and
what would it be without the cast of the
huge enormous upcoming Blockbuster movie
Barbie the movie opens in theaters
everywhere July 21st everybody please
give it up for Margot Robbie Easter eggs
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh that was the best entrance
ever
um like I was selling a car yeah you
were like van away yes it was nice her
leg was over the door it was very classy
um well welcome back to Margo America
you open on the show before but welcome
to the the show ladies I'm thank you so
much
is such an incredible cast of women I
was like excite and men as well but last
time you were here you said kind of
they're all right
um but you said you were going to learn
I think it was French and banjo have you
started it all no Kelly
it's been a busy year I've been learning
Spanish for 20. so my New Year's
resolutions got pushed aside and I'm
still looking for a banjo okay
Jocko could teach you he talks busy a
lot this box is crazy
um but your your mom um Isa was a
teacher right yeah my mom was a French
teacher assistant she was gonna help you
with this look my resolutions yeah I got
you she got you her mom Jocko between
that you've got this cover no excuses
um but no I I love that your mom is a
teacher like my mother was a teacher as
well did you ever feel like you would go
in that field at all like me no yeah no
I think yes see I like my kids not y'all
it was just too much and then even
watching we used to do like take your
daughter to work day yeah visit her and
that that was fun but like kids are
terrible so man but she thank God she
didn't teach at my school she taught at
my younger sibling school yeah and so
they had it way worse so I had a healthy
distance from it it's amazing
yeah I don't think my mom taught at mine
ever either
um we have loved you like on SNL like
everything you do like my I have
literally seen you so much in my
household because Melissa lives next
door to me and your blog you're a
Ghostbusters is my son's favorite I've
seen it a billion times I feel like
they're friends it's awkward
um anyway I have a lifelong fan I am
actually a lifelong friend
I'm wondering though because you're so
funny and I wonder with people that are
on SNL like did you grow up in a like
hysterical family it was everybody funny
people grow up watching a lot of Comedy
like hysterical for you this funny oh no
well my yeah my parents actually are
very funny and they used to like quote
SNL all the time like we are from France
and oh no in all these early SNL quotes
that I just thought were uh English
phrases and so I would say to my teacher
like we are from France and she'd be
like are you well or yeah so
um it was very much in the culture of
the home I love that what a great home
that's fun it was awesome were they
freaking out when you made it onto SNL
uh yeah yeah I was gonna say they
probably not as much as me because then
I had to be on SNL I was scared it's
hysterical well do people still come up
to you and ask for any kind of
impression
um they do I was asked recently what
like when are you going to do Justin
Bieber again and I was like
he's not it's not funny anymore he's a
consummate professional he's a man of
God with a healthy marriage together
honey
yeah that's a statement
my favorite character is the one that I
actually got to do the sketch with you
when you're playing like the like the
older Starlet with the oh yeah you were
you were sweet that was the that's like
one of my favorite characters you've
ever done and I got to see it firsthand
oh man it's so funny
so America
um did you know any of these women
before filming no no like no I didn't
know Margo at all Issa maybe we like
said hi we were on a whole panel
together America it's fine
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no I do remember
yes okay but she's like a long answer I
knew everyone so but this is my problem
because actually my story about Kate is
that I saw her
um uh I saw her at an event and I
thought oh my God that's Kate McKinnon I
have to go say hi and I walked up and I
was like Kate I am your biggest fan and
she's like America
you don't remember and I was like oh no
what we but you went by a different last
name sure and when we were in high
school we attended the same drama summer
program at Northwestern University okay
and it was like one of those moments in
the movie where like your mind rewinds
quickly and forward and then things make
sense and I go you're Kate you're funny
Kate you're the funniest person that was
at the camp and also the funniest person
I'd ever met to that date and of course
you're Kate McCain but I but I remember
because America was in we were all had
our separate shows right and America did
like the most amazing dramatic monologue
and everyone was like America and I was
like oh my own America and I was um I
played a bug in my show and so but it
was like yeah
I'm just gonna not be offended when I
see America tomorrow she's like and you
are here
but as a joke I forget everyone it's
okay it's a joke should have been like
welcome to the show you've never been
here the truth is last night I like
tried to Envision what this was going to
feel like and I thought if Little
America knew that she was standing next
or sitting next to these four people who
I truly deeply deeply like admire and
idolize yeah I like was crying in bed
last night thinking about
so this is like a dream and this is a
Dreamcast this is what making the movie
felt like it was like how how our it's a
dream I love that so Margo is it true
that you had a sleepover like for the
cast before the movie we had a Bobby
sleepover book it was it was as fun as
you as it sounds yeah it was your
welcome idea yeah it was Greta's idea I
can't take credit we all went to like
claridges which is a really gorgeous
hotel in in London we all like shed beds
and like what our pajamas and ordered
room service and played games and found
out that America is like exceptionally
competitive
I am extremely competitive and nobody
told me that it was a sexy Barbie
sleepover so everybody was in like
really pretty silky nightgowns and I was
in like the most Grandma floral twin set
you could imagine yeah I'm how
simultaneously looked like an old lady
but a five-year-old at the same time it
was the cutest and she's 13. while she's
yelling at you while she's screaming at
you but it was very it was it was so
Charming I mean she was like this cutest
little thing you'd put like a toddler in
to go to bed and then she was like
rousing at us for not knowing the rules
yeah
if you're not gonna compete why are you
here
[Music]
was Ryan Gosling so what was it like to
work with him he's so talented it was
again as amazing as it sounds yeah he is
just he's funny man he got very like
Sunny to meeting Chinese he is the most
comedically gifted actor and like I
think he's just so known as being such a
brilliant dramatic actor that people
sometimes like oh yeah he is really
funny he was funny in that thing in this
movie he's funny on like a completely
different level I I ruined like all his
takes because I just laughed for them I
would I actually now watch like the the
edit of the film and I can see Greta
cutting away before I laugh and my like
corn is in my mouth like and then she
cuts back to him because he's so serious
but it's so funny yeah it's so funny oh
and I I was going for it in this movie
it's amazing um Isa Marco so you guys
y'all have a dance scene in the movie
how was that it was so good I saw it
actually yeah it was it
you know it was my first day the dance
sequence happened my first day it was
like I landed and first they sent me
like oh this is they told me it was
gonna be a dance sequence in there I was
like oh cool that's that has nothing to
do with me and then they sent me like
the footage to rehearse it and I was
like you know I was I had something that
I was doing in DC and I had to learn it
in like 24 hours and the cast had been
already working on it and so I was like
this is literally my worst nightmare I'm
not a dancer so I like tried to learn
the routine I was with my friends they
were like girl get it like one two one
two get it one two three four and then
when I landed they were like oh the
dance is completely different
so then I landed my first day meeting
the Cavs was doing this dance number and
it was what a way to break the ice yeah
way to break the ice in my face yeah my
pride
you know it's good to do the dance
rehearsals with us because that was
honestly the funnest part of prepping
this movie is doing we do dance
rehearsals like for probably two weeks
this is definitely why it was so
stressful for you because you didn't get
the two weeks like that we'd all go and
I'd been doing it for like a week on my
own and I was like oh this is so fun
because it's like the kind of dancing
you do like with a hairbrush in front of
your mirror when you're a kid so it's
like silly fun dancing but then like the
other Barbies all started arriving for
the dance rehearsal and then I was like
my ego went through the roof because
they were like like everyone's screaming
and clapping and then we do it all
together and then we'd get like everyone
before shooting we'd get our whole crew
and everything to do like a little dance
warm-up together and it was so fun like
just the vibe the rest of the day would
be just crazy I don't know if you know
but Drew I mean you guys were hers too I
know that y'all dance I know that you
can dance it out you want to show some
moves were you wanting to show us some
moves guys
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
you can tell the year you were born by
that dance alone it's the same year as
me
I don't know
we have an impressive crew 11 Emmys they
got nominated 11 Emmys
amazingly
so Margo can you explain the story of
the movie well uh
Bobby land is perfect and the Bobbies
are having a perfect day after perfect
day and everything's just wonderful in
Bobby land unless you're a Ken
or until you have an existential crisis
which my Bobby does what about the rest
of you like who who's your Barbie
America I'm not a Barbie I mean I am a
Barbie because we're all Barbie's unless
you're a Ken then you're not a Barbie
but um I'm a human in the movie I'm
because there's Barbie there's Barbie
Lane Barbie land and then and in the
last trailer you kind of see the hint of
like Barbie and Ken are headed toward
the real world and in the real world my
character Gloria
uh encounters Barbie and
um it's a it's a connection and and
hijinks ensue from there and I think
that's all I'm allowed to say okay and
then I don't want to spoil everything
who's your Barbie who do you play did
you guys ever have a Barbie like the one
Barbie that you designate as like
her were you like cut their hair burn
their test everything on them that's the
one I play
you're like what if I colored her hair
she needs a haircut
I love your mommy can you do the splits
in real life or do they have to like can
go to about there and then the whole
system breaks down I can't I can't do
this one oh my God way to go then the
editing job oh yes they did this whole
like technical thing where like my legs
are always
um at a 180.
um who's your Barbie Issa my Barbie is
president of Barbie Life yeah you're
very funny
hysterical thank you so much yeah yeah
it was a treat to to be president
somewhere
what if you what would you do if you
really were president funny or serious
uh but a serious health care yeah for
sure everywhere University yeah
um funny like I would be more selfish
like I could just eat everywhere for
free
yeah just walking anywhere anybody's
house if I like your cooking if I like
to cook me a meal I'm coming over yeah
I'm president are you gonna feed me yeah
well America and Margo um Barbie is such
an iconic toy so how does it how does it
feel like I don't know to bring your
story to life I played with Barbies when
I was a kid did y'all I did not you did
not I I was not a Barbie player were you
guys Barbie it wasn't cool too but I
still did like secretly it was a what'd
you say it wasn't cool to play with
Barbies but I said it was like at school
you'd be like Barbies and then at home
I'd be like
so they were like all yes
you know the we would cut the hair and
do all that stuff but I got the fold out
house one Christmas when I was young and
that was every I was oh the Dream House
the folded out like honestly coming into
this movie it was like that was that was
such a priority was those the sets and
then getting them getting to see them be
built right in front of us and they were
just huge real-life versions of the
dream house it looks incredible so
amazing and so beautiful and it's like
the first thing I said to gretels you
know when we first sat down talked about
the movie I was like I'll follow your
vision whatever you want this Barbie
movie to be like let's do that except I
just have one favor please please please
can we have a dream house where she has
a slide that goes from her bedroom down
to her because that is my goal in life
she was like yeah sure that's your thing
that's your thing and I was like yes
that's not like your character Arc like
I thought you were going big or even the
tone of the movie none of that I was
just like I just want that slide so bad
oh my God I'd love that I I think I'm
older than all of you so I loved I was
obsessed with Barbie it's like it was
the cool thing whenever I was a kid now
back like I don't like back then I mean
to be perfectly honest one of the
reasons I didn't play with Barbie is
because like it didn't I didn't feel
reflected in the world of Barbie you
know it was a very Americana version of
beauty and like maybe there was a one
black Barbie and there were white
Barbies and but now it's totally
different and like to be invited to get
to be a part of this narrative where
like Barbie is represents so many more
people yeah it's like it's the it's the
Barbie we deserve you know and that's
what's it's so moving to get to be a
part of this reimagining of this world
of beauty and fun and aspiration where
more of us get to be seen absolutely
it's cold it's cool too and you have
kids because it's like it's come back
around like in such a big way like my
all my little girl her friends they all
have Barbies they're obsessed every time
she's like I want the car I want the
Jeep she's like I'm like wait for a
holiday
um but it's just it's not Tuesday don't
get it every day
um so but anyway it's it's really cool
to see her playing and doing the same
stuff that I did whenever I was a kid
but yeah it's cool to see her kids like
I wonder if your kids will get into it
but my my daughter is like really into
Barbies or not and when I walk in girl
she's got them kissing just like you
just said
she's like they were kissing mom get out
we went okay
um did you play with Barbies I was I was
Barbie curious there were Barbies
you were Barbie and Jason there were
Barbies in the home my my sister
um had a lot of Barbies and they
they had diagnoses these part I mean
these Barbies were messed up
at her hand you know and she but they
were there and she she had spent hours
with her friends uh doing the most I
mean it was like her training as a
comedian and a theater artist she like
came up with all these amazing things
and built an entire world out of them
and I thought wow that's really cool
you're really cool I love my sister I'll
say it here I'll stay here right now
[Music]
[Applause]